what is packs without a game it has a
line weight of about three hours that's
what it's all about
look at these maniacs there's crazy I'm
just saying it yeah it's worth the fuss
I got to play the game and the game is
Elder Scrolls online
I was skeptical about this because I'm a
big skyrim fan everyone loves the world
of Elder Scrolls and in the end I was
like if it's gonna be an MMO it's gonna
feel nerve like the graphics are gonna
be nerve and it's not it looks just like
Skyrim it plays a lot like Skyrim
I always thought Skyrim felt like an MMO
so either Skyrim feels like an MMO or
the Elder Scrolls online doesn't feel
like an MMO point is they both feel they
both feel alike and that's not a bad
thing I played the mage class because if
there's a mage class in the game like
this I'm gonna be the mage the spells
for the mage completely different so
it's a new enough experience
I'm skeptical about the game in the
sense it is still gonna be $15 a month
to play and at this point so many MMOs
are free-to-play I feel like that $15 a
month fee is gonna go away I just think
that time will tell if the game really
pulls it out if this is the greatest MMO
of the past decades and hey maybe they
can keep it but I'm just saying as I
stand right now the Elder Scrolls online
great games can't wait a wait to play it
if you're an elder school span if you're
a Skyrim fan you're gonna end up playing
the game I played the demo I played it
for about a half an hour and it went by
like five minutes so I'm just saying I'm
gonna check it out you'll get a review
of that game from me and another game I
got to play at tax prime is Batman
Arkham origins
again looking forward to this game but I
was a bit I was a bit skeptical because
I love Batman Arkham Asylum I love
Arkham City and this is done by a
different company so it's like alright
oh what's the what's the catch you know
Kevin Conroy is not doing the voice of
Batman Mark Hamill is not doing the
voice of Joker played about 15 minutes
of the game kind of say it jumps right
into it it's really familiar combat in a
really good way you know all the
tutorial lights are coming up like yeah
Bush r1 while you're flying you know
exactly what to do if you're a fan of
the other Arkham games you can literally
jump right into this game met the Joker
in this game you wouldn't know it's not
Mark Hamill voicing with Joker
like it sounds just like Mark Hamill
which it doesn't have to sound like Mark
Hamill but it was really cool to not
have that culture shock really like this
is clearly it's not Mark Hamill at all
another thing about the game that I'm
not saying this concerning but it is
different is when I was punching guys it
did sound a little different like who
said it didn't
didn't feel the same it didn't feel like
you were bruising their ribs it felt
like you were bruising their epidermis
I'm just saying the sound effect was a
little different so you're like whoa at
least it's a guy who does sound like
Mark Hamill Batman in this one he does a
good job there - he's raspy and dark
he's not Conroy but he is a good younger
Batman I'm looking forward to this game
I already pre-ordered it before today
because I had a really sweet Joker
statue that comes with it but that's
just my Joker fetish thing going on but
now I don't regret it I'm like okay I
have the Joker statue coming and a good
game so our merchants looking forward to
that - what can I say I love packs this
is why because now I know that I'm not
just getting a joker statue I'm getting
the experience